this is a keynote I gave in Stockholm
crushed the crowd because that's just
how I do in Stockholm they call it a
syndrome what is the Stockholm Syndrome
can somebody Google it while I because
I'm using this intro anyway voice baby
voice you guys are my hostages yeah I
get it
Stockholm Syndrome wow that's cool
watch his keynote tell me what you think
[Music]
hey Stockholm so I'm very excited to be
here want to talk about the one thing
that I'm positive that we are all
connected by I think one of the
challenges that I have as somebody who
likes to do speeches is that I'm
obsessed with being consumer-centric
right at the end of the day I think
every success I have comes far more from
humility and listening than it does for
my big mouth and all my talking and
things of that nature and one of the
keys that I think a lot about when I
speak is getting a sense of who's in the
audience and reverse-engineering
obviously I can't give the same speech
to a roomful of 22 year old founders
that are trying to build machine
learning companies as I can to a bunch
of 16 year olds who are trading
cryptocurrency
in the same way that I can't to a 48
year old executive fortune 500 CMO crowd
and so I'm always kind of weaving I have
a thesis it's very simple it's right
there iDate trade attention it is going
to be the core of what I want to talk to
you about because it's the only thing
that if you're in here as an executive
or b2b how many people here are in b2b
the b2b space raise your hands high
great b2c great how many people here are
entrepreneurs and own their own business
raise your hand great how many don't and
they work somewhere great 50 50 50 50
right so I think what's very scary about
that in my ambition that everybody here
enjoys the talk is that there's a lot of
nuances and practicalities that play out
very differently but the one thing that
100% connects every single person in
this room is the need to get somebody's
attention before they tell them how good
their thing is whether you're sitting
here and very altruistic and are trying
to raise money for a non-profit or if
you want to sell a bottle of wine it's
all the same game which is very simply
where is the attention how do you then
communicate in that environment
contextually to the attention and then
can you create the output that you're
looking for I spend a lot of time in
this I've spent a lot of time in this
whole life when I was six years old and
moved to Edison New Jersey for a lot of
you that don't know me I was born in the
Soviet Union immigrated to the United
States when I was three lived a very
humble life studio apartment seven
family members you know spent my first
18 years taking one family vacation you
know basically after I was 11 or 12
years old had to buy everything for
myself you know very very fortunate to
be honest taught me really had to get
mine and taught me a lot of the things
that have made me successful but the
interesting thing was I was an
entrepreneur right from the beginning
I'm 42 years old and in America you know
good grades was the only way somebody
was judged in the 80s and 90s and I did
not have good grades and so for a long
period of my time I was not winning I
was a losing player a lot of my friends
parents looked down on me because their
kids got A's and I got apps and I used
to sit there and look at them when they
would make fun of me this is the parents
not making fun of me in a mean way but
they would make a slide comments and I
would sit there and say don't you
realize that your straight a kid is
gonna work for me one day and I said
it's so basic anyway when I was seven
years old and started my first kind of
business six seven years old it was 11 8
stands which is very cliche in the
United States but I took a very
different approach I had four or five of
them because I commenced manipulated my
friends to stand behind them all day in
the summer and sell lemonade and what I
did was I walked up and down the streets
of New Jersey and I would sit and try to
figure out which tree and which post and
which sign I could put my signs on and I
did that by literally sitting on the
ground and watching cars drive by for
three to four hours in the middle of the
summer
this is what came natural to me it came
natural to me DNA that I was trying to
follow your eyes while you were driving
and try to figure out was it better to
be put here we're here or up there and
that's basically been the story of my
life today today I do that I try to
figure out when are you gonna
and time on Instagram or snapchat or
Pinterest or LinkedIn how soon is it
before you all interact with an Alexa or
a Google home device to get information
or buy things where is your attention in
a ultra stat kind of future world of AR
and VR and what is it about machine
learning what are we doing where are we
going what happens to restaurants with
self-driving cars if we're gonna eat in
there how can i story tell to you when
you're driving today I story tell to you
through voice right because when you're
driving it's passive you can consume it
how does that change
why is while everybody's obsessed with
video consumption I'm going and spending
all my time on audio because I know
actually watch this this may be very
interesting for this crowd how many
people here are fans of my content and
consume my content and don't raise your
hand because you're trying to be nice
just if you do raise your hands all
right first of all that sucks
alright one more time hands up who do
great up you how many of you in the last
year or two have started listening more
to the podcast and watching a little
less of the video raise your hands
that to me is the most interesting thing
thank you that to me is the most
interesting thing happening right now
which is I think we're about to live
through the explosion of voice and I'll
get to that in a minute but I want to go
back because there's so many people in
the b2b space what day trading attention
means is that everything that you're
gonna hear coming out of my mouth around
voice Instagram influencers Facebook in
this moment has the potential to not
matter tomorrow I doubt it cuz it
usually takes a little more time but
literally 15 months ago I made a video
saying that Instagram was in trouble
that snapchat was growing very quickly
and starting to penetrate
thirty-year-olds that Facebook was much
bigger than people realized at a younger
age and that I did not see a place for
Instagram to play as snapchat started
winning that generation literally a
month later and I didn't know this they
came out with all the features that
snapchat has and here we are 15 months
later but basically after I made the
video it was
literally a hundred days later that
Instagram became the most important
platform of attention and that's why I
call it day trading where I used to call
it if you came to a talk five years ago
that slide would have said market in the
year that you live in right my thesis is
that most of you especially in the b2b
space are wasting an ungodly amount of
time and money and energy on places
where people are not paying attention
because of history and tradition and
that's how you've always done it and
that your underspending where the
retention actually is and that's where
the arbitrage is that's the opportunity
that is where I and people that trade
the way I do make their wealth build
their businesses but I had to change it
from marketing in the year that you live
in to day trading attention because
everything's happening so fast
it's it's unbelievable to me how big of
a deal this is and how quickly it's
changing but here are some of the
frameworks I understand for everybody in
this room if you do not produce content
and story tell on this device you are
becoming unbelievably irrelevant by the
minute if you do not understand how to
take your brochure or your booth at a
trade conference or your print ad in a
catalog and convert it to being relevant
on here you are becoming increasingly
irrelevant the biggest mistake that this
room is gonna make is they're gonna say
things like but my 59 year old target
audience isn't living on there and they
will make grave business mistakes over
the next three to four years based on
their romantic point of view on
technology instead of the reality of
what's actually happening my friends I
think in only practicality I was brought
up in an environment where eventually
after having a successful baseball card
business that I was making three to four
thousand dollars a weekend in I was
dragged into my dad's liquor store and
had to help build that family business I
built my dad's business from a three to
a sixty million dollar business in a
very short period of time on the back of
making every penny work like a dollar my
dad's business was doing three point
seven million dollars in sales on ten
percent gross profit which means we had
three hundred seventy thousand dollars
before expenses and I built that
business
from that's based 260 million in five
years with no ma no VC's because what I
did was I date traded attention in 1996
to 2001 that meant two big bets that I
made one was email how many people here
have done email marketing in their
careers raise your hands please raise
them hi I want to get a sense great
so you'll love this in 1996 I had an
email newsletter that had 91 percent
open rates it had 91 percent open rates
not because it was so incredible what I
was writing in there I was writing by
this wine click here it was incredible
because nobody was doing email marketing
in 1996 it was a new phenomenon how many
people here had email in 1998 raise your
hands
great so for the youngsters here you're
about to learn something cuz most of the
stuff you're going to know in 1998
youngsters this is how email happened
somebody would send an email and us old
folk we would open and read every single
[ __ ] email the supply and demand of
attention it was a new medium and all of
us treated email the way we traded mail
you had to kind of properly look at it
we have now no longer do that we now
care so much about our time that the
reason we don't unsubscribe from
newsletters that we don't read anymore
is because it takes longer to
unsubscribe than it does to just delete
it is time arbitrage it is attention and
this is how we play the second bet I
made happened a little bit later you
know when I started winelibrary.com
Google didn't exist so it's just
fascinating to think about very much the
themes of the gentleman right before me
about how early this is how much we
don't know that's how I think about
marketing you know Google didn't exist
for most of this room when we started
our careers the internet didn't exist
for most of the people in this room so
I've lived a life where everything was a
fad not just snapchat the whole [ __ ]
internet was a fad when I started my
career and so what's fascinating to me
is the next bet I made was Google
AdWords Google AdWords had come out and
for five cents a click before they
raised the minimum to
and sense I was buying up every wine
term and I was able to buy words like
wine and Cabernet and champagne for five
and ten cents a click and very honestly
it is one of the best things I ever did
in my career and it is no question one
of the worst things I ever did in my
career I bet very big and it worked very
great but I was young and I was doing
everything Direct Mail print radio
television I was branding I was
marketing but I understand on Google
AdWords I had I always like to say I had
the best hand in poker and I didn't go
all-in it was working but I didn't
understand at that point in my career
how much it was working and when I hear
like somebody introduced me and say from
3 to 60 million dollars and it's
impressive and I'm glad and I love it
it's my family it matters to me
but every time I hear it I say to myself
it should have been 200 and I'll tell
you it's why I stand here in front of
you and I want to use that as a segue to
why and I want them the light is
powerful but I want to see your faces I
need everybody to understand this I
don't care if you're selling to 17
farmers a 1 million dollar you know
aggregation system in a b2b environment
every person in this room has to
understand how unbelievably underpriced
and how unbelievably powerful Facebook
advertising is right now right this
second the scalable underpriced
attention in our society and by the way
if you are doing business in the Nordics
it's an even better deal than it is in
the US because it's a marketplace and it
only reacts I love you guys for that it
only reacts to how much money you guys
pump into the system when BMW and SAS
and coca-cola actually wake up and
understand how underpriced Facebook's
ads are the price of Facebook ads is
going to skyrocket and you will regret
like I do in not spending money in it
today there is an unbelievable amount of
people in this room
who have opinions on how Facebook works
for their business without ever running
a Facebook ad we are making headline
reading and emotional decisions about
the current state of marketing and
opportunity we are not relying enough on
practitioners I have watched people buy
hundred million dollar contracts from
one Facebook ad I've seen it not I
guessed it I heard about it we work with
the GES and the S APs and the biggest
brands in the world
we are grossly under estimating it's
amazing to me that people sit around and
talk about Trump and brexit and Arab
Spring and these macro unbelievable
historic cultural shifts in our society
and then an hour later when they talk
about their little business their
hundred million dollar 500 million
dollar one billion dollar 10 billion
dollar little business and they don't
think Facebook can affect it it is
unbelievable naivete and that and that's
at best at worst you were being grossly
negligent in how you're running your
business out of the laziness to not
become educated on what is actually
happening in our game so I'm fascinated
by this I think this is the great
opportunity this is a generational
situation if you look at the history of
marketing television radio the internet
now the social layer on top of the
internet every time there is a huge
shift of attention somewhere new
enormous wealth is made an enormous
wealth is lost and this my friends is
the biggest of them all the amount of
attention shifting is extraordinary but
I want you to hear something I do not
believe that this is about traditional
media versus digital media for example I
think one of the great wastes of money
in the world is buying programmatic
banner ads and pre rolls across the web
for $5 CPMs because it's cheap I also
believe in America for example that the
Superbowl ad that cost five point five
million dollars for thirty seconds is by
far the best deal in marketing because
everybody in America will see
yet and you get unbelievable awareness
so for me I'm fascinated by the nuances
I think you can waste all your money on
Facebook if you don't know how to use it
my friends what's the ROI of a piano
what's the ROI of a piano let me help
you for Gary Vaynerchuk zero I can't
play for [ __ ] but for Billy Joel and
Elton John the ROI was a billions of
dollars the ROI of a basketball is zero
for me for LeBron a billion this is not
about does this stuff work this is about
do you know what to do with it and the
reality is you don't know what to do
with it the far majority of people in
here have never been practitioners of
the modern-day storytelling and media
planning and execution for a business
result and that is where the opportunity
is I'm fascinated by how big this
actually is I am I laugh when people
don't understand how much change is
happening and so this rant this passion
I start this keynote with is very simple
it is my hope that one one one person in
this room decides to go back home and
run their business properly and it's not
very complicated it's about becoming
educated education matters just the
education of the day always matters more
the fact that so many of you have not
spent 30 hours which is a lot but very
little based on the ambitions that you
have for yourself or your organizations
that you've not spent 30 hours to either
read on Google or watch videos on
YouTube to how to run an Instagram ad
how to place a snapchat filter how to
plan Facebook media and you think that
even if you've done it you've outsourced
it to a 25 year old who gets it is
fascinating to me who's the biggest
advertiser on Google in the first six
years of Google Amazon
Amazon was the biggest advertiser on
Google in the first year six years of
Google AdWords it is not a coincidence
that Amazon is one of the biggest
companies in the world they used the
underpriced attention to build their
company who was the biggest advertiser
of television in the prime of the 1970s
and 80s when television was at scale and
underpriced Proctor and Gamble
it is not a coincidence that Tide and
Dove and Procter & Gamble became the
biggest consumer packaged goods products
in the world this is very basic what
were the biggest sports in America in
the 1940s and 50s baseball horse-racing
and boxing who also spent the most time
distributing content on radio what was
the biggest sports in the last 20 years
in America the NFL the biggest spender
the biggest executor of content in the
medium the sport matched the content
there's two young men right there doing
tricks with soccer balls on Instagram
and YouTube it's because that content
and that formula works on that platform
and they didn't have to get signed by
somebody to be able to make that content
they just went direct to the consumer
and then Adidas the biggest brand in the
world in that sport comes to them and
wants to do business with them I am
fascinated by the naivete / audacity of
the 99% of people in the business world
today in their disrespect for social
media why don't I help you guys let me
help you with something the word social
media is the problem you know that right
the problem here is a branding problem
social media has a branding problem when
I say the word social media for a lot of
executives in this room especially you
b2b people that is a nuance that is an
sprinkle that is a nice-to-have
that is a it's gonna be here one day but
doesn't matter to me when I hear the
word social media I think very simply I
think this is the remote control of our
society and I know that 50% of every
minute spent by human beings on earth
zero to a hundred years old is spent on
a social media site
fifty percent I hear social media my
brain says the current state of the
internet and I have a funny feeling that
you would have a harder time betting
against the current state of the
internet for your business than social
media so now I implore you and my hope
and dream is this audience starts to
think about this just a little bit
differently not because I'm passionate
and I'm going hard but because there are
truths and what I'm saying and you know
them and you feel them and you also know
that you can't call the bluff one way or
the other meaning I'm a big fan of a be
testing if you believe that your print
your radio your Google Ads your
sponsorships your booths at events are
better than producing videos that people
actually want to watch on Facebook and
then retargeting them and putting them
into a sales funnel and then closing
them well then you should test them to
me the fascination is how anybody in
2018 is not testing at scale these
phenomenons and so I'm trying to put
pressure on the collective system really
to be very frank and I hope everybody
understands this none of you are my
clients you guys aren't my brothers and
sisters I'm about to leave Stockholm
very soon and go back to New York I
don't give a [ __ ] if you do anything I'm
talking about
I really don't there's really only two
agendas I have here number one Tyler's
filming it and in four years when CPM
costs on Facebook are thirty and forty
dollars I'm just gonna post a video clip
of this moment and it's gonna say I told
you so
number two which has been much more
fruitful for me is that when I do this
and I talk this way which is practical
not in Phatak not passionate practical
I'm talking about what's actually
happening now and everybody's acting and
executing spending money and energy like
seven years ago this is not futuristic
talk this is today I can talk to you
about four
to reality and AR and machine learning
and voice all day long that's not
practical for anybody in here but
selling a contract in a construction
company on Facebook which seems
extremely foreign to the collective is
happening every day for the two or three
practitioners of this skill in that
platform and it's converting a hell of a
lot better than your direct mail and all
the other [ __ ] you're spending money and
energy on period but you don't know that
cuz you haven't tested it I have my run
Direct Mail and Facebook for Wine
Library
I run direct mail and Facebook for all
my SAS products that I'm an investor in
I look at this stuff every day and so I
say this to have it on the record
and number two it isn't an amazing
feeling when I fly home I will get an
email that says four and a half years
ago I was in Alabama I heard your talk
and I own this and I did this and here's
my business now I'm looking to get my
high from an email that says you came to
Stockholm in late 2017
I didn't even know who you were when you
went on stage but you yelled at me so
aggressively I said [ __ ] it I'll try it
and then this happened and so that's
where I'm at mentally I'm excited I
think the thing that you have to hear
for me is a couple more things before we
get into Q&A and please that are we
using the app here I assume we are so
please if you've got what I would
implore right now and then I'll go and
rest my talk is if you have a basic
social media digital media marketing you
know branding 101 question to ask it
because this is the environment to do it
right because you can see this
theoretical talk on YouTube that we're
here together now so if you have a very
direct question I am a lawyer how the
hell do I use Facebook to get more like
please ask right now take out your app
and start asking questions while I keep
going because I the QA part that's
coming soon is is the part here's the
part that's tricky I'm right on the
framework of where the attention is the
problem is is if you go home and spend
$5,000 on Facebook ads the creative is
the variable of your success
the picture the video the words you
write in that post are the difference
between zero sales and a thousand sales
zero dollars in donations and a million
dollars in donations my vulnerability my
kryptonite
to my thesis is the creative I have your
attention right now
this will be no different than Facebook
right this framework of the event we're
in right now I have your attention this
is a talk you came to listen you're here
you're all paying attention ish I see a
couple of you on your phone keep doing
your thing it's more important but if
the content of my speech is not good and
not interesting I've wasted my
opportunity with my creative to create
the event that I'm looking for right so
the thing that I'm very passionate about
is please understand what is actually
happening in this device and here's
what's happening this is a place where
math and data and science mash into art
and creativity and equally both of them
have to be respected the short-term
financial businesses running here care
about math too much the overly long term
and ideological and artistic people in
this room are going to over here and not
practical about the math the balance of
the two is everything and the platform
of Facebook and likes and these are
stream mentality sites that have our
attention right now Instagram and things
that nature is incredibly important to
respect both for example talking about
stream dynamics Twitter because of the
nature of the context is overpriced ads
because the ad prices have a floor and
they're not converting as well and the
attention on Twitter is very different
than it is on Facebook and Instagram
thus making the inventory overpriced in
my opinion as we sit here today so the
creative that you put in Twitter matters
just as much everywhere else but if
you're paying too much to get in front
of somebody it's not going to be as
valuable this is basic supply and demand
of attention and
then framed on top of it do you
understand the context of the creative
you have to put into it now let me go a
little 201 on this it's super important
for you to do one thing it's important
for you to do what I did before I took
this stage which is reverse-engineer the
audience the number one mistake
everybody's making on social media
content right now is they're using the
same content and they're spreading it
throughout all the platforms and they're
using social as distribution not as a
native place to story tell let me
explain all of you sitting here how many
people here consume content on more than
one social network raise your hand
fantastic majority of this room so
you're gonna understand this and this is
fascinating and after I tell you this I
can't wait for you to spend the next day
or two realizing how interesting this
nuance is I am me I'm Gary
right when I go into Instagram my
psychology is different than when I go
into Twitter my psychology is different
than when I go into Facebook every one
of you uses these platforms differently
when you're on LinkedIn
that's an amazing ring when I go in it's
really funny when I go into Instagram my
mindset is younger its swag year it is
just different there's a youthfulness
there's a pulse there's a cultural
aspect that even the copy that I write
with my two thumbs is different slang
than what I would write on LinkedIn than
what I would write on Twitter then than
what I would write on Facebook
understand that when you put a picture
or words or video on one of these
platforms the person you're trying to
reach even though you targeted ads
across all of them for forty four to
forty five year old women with two
children and $100,000 income even though
she is the same person her mindset is
different in every platform and that
context that nuance is imperative you
also have to respect the platform
Instagram is a platform that only allows
you today to make a video that is only
one minute long that is a difference
storytelling restriction than if you're
making a four and a half minute video on
Facebook too many companies that are
advanced in here will make one video and
then edit it down for the one-minute
version by their best half-assed efforts
from the four-minute version that they
put on Facebook without creating
narrative Li for that platform or deeply
understanding how to what I would call
DJ the content into the platform if
you're into music then you realize over
the last 20 years we've seen the growth
of DJ culture it is a different skill
set than being the person that creates
the original song if you become great at
being a DJ off of a piece of a content
to the six or seven logos that matter at
the bottom of my screen down here if you
can become a great DJ if you can take a
piece of content if you can understand
what you want to say what message are
you trying to make me understand use my
dentist service buy my SAS product use
my bank hire my law firm work with me
donate for me vote for me buy me donate
for me if you understand what you're
trying to get across and you understand
that it's words audio and video in the
way we've communicated for the last 100
plus years and you understand how to
respect and I mean really respect this
and this and this and this and that and
that and understand how they're
different how they work inside out
spend the 30 to 40 hours to become
educated on how they work and then
actually with your own fingers place it
run it and watch it and do that for the
next six months you have a shot to be
successful and if you do not you can
still be successful but you're doing it
at your own peril every day goes by this
is grabbing attention now you may not
like that you might be very upset that
the kids are in their phone the whole
time but you have to make me a promise
you have to leave your opinions about
technology at the door when you walk
into the office and run your business
because your romance is gonna put you
out of business
and I want to debate you on your romance
when you go to a restaurant and you see
a couple sitting there and both of them
are on the phone and not talking you
love to nudge your partner and say isn't
that sad that's terrible right oh look
at this that's terrible my look at it
very differently when I walk into a
restaurant and I see a couple sitting
there and both of them are on the phone
the whole thirty times I get excited I
feel better for them I'm happy for them
let me tell you why I'm serious my man
let me tell you why it's very simple
thirty years ago that same couple
sitting at that restaurant they didn't
talk to each other they sat across for
each other all of you have seen this all
of you I'm looking around a crab nice
you know this is not 14 year old girls
in the crowd we're a little older here
how many people over 35 raise your hand
perfect all of you have seen what I saw
15 years ago which is you went to a
restaurant
and you just happen to notice while you
were doing your thing two people sitting
there a couple not saying a [ __ ] word
to each other right my friends
technology has not changed us technology
has exposed us the reason those two
people are sitting there and both on the
phone is because they don't like each
other and when I see two people sitting
there in their 40s 50s 60s 70s and 80s
normally both on the phone and not
talking to each other I see it as a
mitzvah I'm happy for them because 20
years ago they had nothing to do and
they had to get through that hour hating
each other not saying a [ __ ] word but
now they can look at their YouTube video
and be happy it's true
things are changing you have to
understand your culture I'm awfully
aware of the different nuances of the
culture of the Nordics versus the US
when I speak everyone's and I'm Taipei
for even America people like we're
different here we're subtle I understand
I'm not asking you to do anything
uncomfortable I'm asking you to
communicate and not waste your money
it's not groundbreaking this is not
revolutionary it's a bad idea to waste
money and just because your organization
scores it that way
or your boss believes in that doesn't
mean it's right and so we are living
through a very big culture change the
culture change is phenomenal this is all
time change 15 years ago if you went on
the internet to go on a dating site and
went on a date you were weird now that
is the norm can you imagine if I told
the parents in this room 20 years ago
that I'm from the future
and let me tell you what's gonna happen
in 20 years you're gonna rather your 14
year old girl go into a stranger's car
every day to get around the town than to
drive herself because you would think
that's safer nobody would have bought me
selling them uber nobody would have
bought 20 years ago that kids would be
going into strangers you were taught how
many people over 35 we were taught you
don't go into strangers cars at all
costs now we're paying a [ __ ] premium
to go inside of them the culture has
changed it's not changing it's not
coming there are 60 year-old men in here
who texted a poop emoji to their friend
last night the same 60 year old
executive who said what's an emoji 18
months ago the same 60 year old
executive who ten years ago said they
would never be on Facebook the same
60-year old executive for 15 years ago
said to me I'm not getting a cellphone
my pager works just fine we as a culture
do not like change
and in that we lose it is time for you
to go on the offense not the defense
because I have a funny thing to tell you
about technology everything I believe in
didn't exist 15 years ago not the
smartphone not YouTube not Facebook not
apps nothing did not exist and if you
think the last 15 years have been crazy
wait to see what technology is gonna do
in the next 15 years this is nothing you
know what this is this iPhone X you know
this is this is a pager this is a pager
and then 10 years this is gonna look so
archaic we're not gonna know what to do
with ourselves so let me ask you a
question how many people in this room
right now are retiring in the next 10
years and I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and sell your company for a
billion dollars and live on an island I
mean you're old and you're finished
raise your hand 10 years show me okay
great
great so for the 13 of you you can take
this with somewhat importance but for
the rest of you my friends you have to
understand what we're living through
we're living through a race we're about
to run a marathon in technology
technology will eat up every aspect of
everything always and forever it's how
it works the book stores were first then
it was people that owned taxi services
then it was the hotel industry with
Airbnb but it will keep going the
biggest TV networks in the world now
that there's OTT this will keep going
everything just cuz you have big
contracts with the biggest companies in
the world
what's that contract worth when that
company is not alive this is real and so
we're about to run a marathon and the
reason I stress on you to be good at
that is not because I think that's the
end-all be-all
but you have no chance to be good at AR
and VR and machine learning and
cryptocurrency and everything else
that's coming next if you did not ground
yourself in this you can't run a forty
mile marathon
now on the spot if you haven't been on
the treadmill for the last six months
and running little mini races to prepare
and if you are not adapting this
psychologically first religion first and
then becoming a practitioner you need to
be the architect the general contractor
and the plumber because if you don't you
will lose and so I implore you while
it's easy it's [ __ ] easy to learn
this while it's easy
you better get serious about this
because the next wave of technology is
gonna gobble you up and I implore you to
take this speech very very seriously
thank you
[Music]
Gary B I think should I stand there or
do you know anything you want
can I come close to you let's get real
close okay thank you that was great and
we all feel like dinosaurs now how many
feels like if you'd like a dinosaur out
there yes quite a few did I say
something that was action thank you one
more time dinosaur who feels like a
dinosaur you know what's amazing about
this game literally in 60 days you don't
have to what I love about this game is
you could be a dinosaur of everything
but good news that already happened this
is one of the most liberating things I
can tell somebody and by the way I'm not
saying it to make you feel good cuz I
think you can tell I don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm saying because it's true the fact
that you can go from a zero a dinosaur I
don't know what the hell he's talking
about or more imporantly I understand
but I know nothing about it
in 60 days and forty hours you can know
everything that's incredible free
information who's over thirty five raise
your hand real quick tell these kids
about something called
the library like we used to go somewhere
to get him for me what do you want to
know what do you want to know in our
fingers in a second so what excites me
is sure you could feel like a dinosaur
sure it might feel intense but I see it
as optimism not negativity this is an
opportunity for all of you and the
biggest thing is you're gonna live much
longer than you think and so there's a
lot of people here under 40s 50s and 60s
who think they're wrapping up and
finishing it and it was passed where all
the opportunity for happiness
professionally is in the next 30 years
between 50 and 80 because you can start
your own business around your passion
around ice hockey or or beverages or
soup or suits or sneakers this is so big
that I just think people are under
estimating how great it can be thank you
we feel much better I actually do it's
good I keep the questions coming in you
heard Gary this is a free consultation
so just use the time and I have a
question here from mark what about ads
on Facebook
for nonprofit organizations does it work
how should it be done I was in I'm on
the I'm AM L a well member for an
organization called charity water that
I'd love for all of you to look at
because it's run by a club promoter and
an entrepreneur which is why it's being
successful right we're doing very well
we're really trying to bring fresh water
to the entire world Scott Harrison is an
all-time great nonprofit executive in
the presentation on Sunday night which
you know was remarkable the biggest
growth for the company has been getting
$5 return on investment for every dollar
spent on Facebook my friends listen it's
under priced attention it's $6 CPM and
it and you can target 44 year old Korean
women who like hockey I mean it's crazy
do you understand
it's crazy what it can do it's why it's
changing our macro geopolitical climate
it's going to be $45 CPM in about three
years that's it it's just a lot better
to pay six dollars instead of 45mm
especially when you have to spend
hundreds of thousands and millions so
yes it can work for nonprofits another
question how do you think your strategy
regarding visibility in marketing on
Instagram and snapchat would work if if
this is hypothetical or not I don't know
I am CMO of patek philippe or ms many
people in marketing would say that it's
proven that luxury brands lose brand
value and positioning if they're visible
in the wrong context with the mass
brands I think there's a lot of things
in there in that statement I would say
number one ego is mixed in there I would
say naivete is mixed there those two
sort of things that stand out I'm
empathetic I'm empathetic to why Rolex
or Cartier or Austin Martin may think
that this is below them
it's also why Tiffany's and Austin
Martin
and Rolex will go out of business over
the next decade let me say it very clear
one more time go out to business in the
next decade or 15 years if they don't
act they will because every day that
goes let me tell you something about
social media and luxury brands none of
them were there eight years ago they're
all they are now they're just half
pregnant because they're [ __ ] snobs
run by snobs and you know what's amazing
about meritocracy and capitalism and
open market dynamics snobs die okay this
is not a just personal opinion based on
where you come from no ya know any look
listen I I don't think I can win if I
have personal opinions
I want Christie's is selling $800,000
products on Instagram is that a good
enough answer what do you want like do
you not understand how society works do
not understand that every rich person 35
to 45 only lives on Instagram and
doesn't even know what the [ __ ] bog is
like do you live in the world nobody me
I'm being really click like listen this
is an opportunity like our people that
tone-deaf or is it that you're not doing
it because inside the companies of these
luxury brands they don't have an
internal mmm that knows how to score the
metrics of the new modern platforms so
they over value the impressions of print
oh by the way for anybody that's not in
the business the way that print is
valued on how many people see it is they
give eight times circulation value - how
many of the magazines are printed so for
high net worth brand where you're in
with high net worth brands prints five
hundred thousand or a hundred thousand
copies they give you the fact that 800
thousand people will see your ad on page
237 of that magazine because you know
everybody takes the robbed report and
Vogue and GQ and leaves it on a plane
and then somebody else gets there picks
it up and opens
and carefully goes to page 237 and
consumes your ad so listen I think to
answer your question my personal
experience no I think it's their
personal experience of how they grew up
or more importantly how they wish it
would be because a lot of people that
work at brands like that like the
inclusive on a pedestal nature of that
job and by the way I don't blame you
enjoy it while it lasts
okay we have quite a few questions that
asked about what is that like after
Facebook when that becomes too expensive
what's the next thing I don't know if
you guys know but I'm not Nostradamus I
have no idea and that's the beauty of
day trading attention and trying not to
have opinions I don't know I don't know
if AR will be here fast enough that
there's something that gets brought up I
don't know how soon we're gonna wear
contact lenses and live in a virtual
reality world not in the real world I
don't know what I know is that I have a
mental mindset a religion to know what
it is I in 1996 would stand up here and
tell you about email I in 2001 would
tell you about Google I in 2004 would
tell you about programmatic banners and
YouTube I in 2007 would tell you about
Twitter like I don't know at all I know
that what got me here isn't gonna get me
to the next place and I know that the
market much like luxury brands doesn't
care about little o me
so when it's here in four years I'm
gonna do a lot of work and stay up late
and educate myself and use my intuition
and my skill of consumer behavior to
figure out how to story tell in the
place that is now emerged okay and so
then you have to go out for the
knowledge so your intuition will work
the right way where do you sort of go
everywhere where we are currently so I
will tell you the pulse of culture no
question lives on Instagram you should
spend an hour a day just searching
Instagram hashtags and following a lot
of people and then reading what people
leave you should spend an
if lemon fries if you're a strategist a
psychologist a you know somebody who
anthropologists if you're curious about
culture it is playing out in your eyes
on Instagram it is the pulse the
heartbeat of the emerging cultures I
knew that eight-year-old girls were
gonna make slime two years ago it's
right there couldn't he have stopped it
I could have but that wouldn't have
allowed me to invest a lot of money into
the Elmer's glue company you did I sure
did and if I took my coin base out right
now not that not that I'm a genius and I
surely didn't bet enough money but if I
take my coin base account out right now
I just want to be very accurate so
there's no confusion by paying attention
to culture and betting on people's you
know kind of actions I bought on let's
see here on February 18 2014
I bought my Bitcoin not last week what
what happens when you stay curious and
humble as you start listening when you
start listening and executing it allows
you to have the audacity to start
talking that is a good strategy thank
you you're welcome
yes this one
how important is personal brand
comparing to the company brand as an
entrepreneur look I think everybody has
different levers if you're highly
charismatic and extremely handsome you
should build a personal brand I think if
you're an introvert and you don't like
people you shouldn't it's true
look it's very true there are an amazing
amount of people building incredible
businesses organizations governments
nonprofits and businesses that you'll
never hear of they're more comfortable
behind the scenes and that's incredible
not everybody should be out there doing
you have to self-awareness is the magic
knowing who you are is the magic not
being on stage and making a joke right
so I think it's incredible if you're
good at it and you like it and you like
people and you can take the heat the key
the key to a personal brand is humility
like when I put out content there's a
lot of comments that I'm a jackass or
I'm too cocky or I suck
if you can't quantify that you won't
produce so you have to know who you are
if you're doing it for the right reasons
and you have to deploy empathy to why
your personality may not work for
somebody because everybody's got an
opinion and they're allowed to share it
mm GZ and it danger in the social media
bubble are we getting more stupid by
being fed witness that confirmed what we
already know or think no I think we've
been historically stupid
that's very true here's a very simple
question life is binary when we have
this conversation about social media
manipulating us life's binary I'm gonna
ask you very simple would you rather
have the society that we live in be in a
place where they can consume content
from lots and lots of voices or did you
like 1973 better when two or three or
one old white dude could tell you what
to think you can't have both I mean that
like all of a sudden traditional media
has been this incredible golden era for
all the people that are scared by the
new regime really you liked when two
people control the media I'm thrilled
all these men are being outed for their
transgressions that happens when the
world's open not when they're friends
with the people that control the media
your choice but I think most people
would agree that yes it's better now in
many ways but still we have mr. Putin
and we have other realities that really
are affecting democracy and what about
that are we supposed if taters get to
play too well you know yes like like the
naivete of the human race that
everything's gonna stay the same
everything is gonna Evan flow and
everything will always happen flow I
just AM an unbelievable buyer of us I'm
an optimist of us we've been around a
long time we have figured this out it
always gets better you may not like it
there might be something you don't like
but it always gets better you know
what's scarier than social media the
Black Plague I just believe in us like
there will always have been flow I mean
Putin is executing my thesis which is
the media controls thinking and he can
use the tools as much as anybody else
but this is where I get really mad at
human beings we love to blame somebody
else
Vladimir Putin did not come to my house
and make me read the propaganda you read
it you're a big girl you're a big boy
stop pointing fingers social and digital
and the new way communication works is
exposing us it's not changing us you
know how the Facebook algorithm works if
you keep clicking and reading that stuff
it will show you more you want to try an
incredible and spit actually you know
what I've never done this you want to
try an incredible experiment go to
Facebook how many people use Facebook
raise your hand great go to Facebook and
search at the top which people don't do
search at the top a subject that you
like something you like hockey
peanut butter and jelly eSports whatever
you want choose suits parenting
something you like search it then what
shows up like all the posts like them
all like them all
and read three of them stay in the
screen and read three of them and then
tell me what your newsfeed does the next
month tell me how much the bad guys are
manipulating you you're manipulating
yourself you don't want to own up to it
but okay look let's have a real ixora
little trump says we don't want any
immigrants in this country especially
not the ones from Belarus okay yeah and
every argument for the immigrants being
in United States won't reach people's
feeds so this this is the reality and
they want to throw you after the country
how do you go about to sort of get into
this space to reach these people so
there's a lot of questions in that let's
start with this first of all Facebook
has a lot of attention but it doesn't
control all the airwaves it doesn't
control all the communication there
there's nobody who's doing anything in a
macro that people aren't aware of it's
not like people spend 100 percent of
their time in their feed let me tell you
something in America if you only watch
Fox News or if you only watch CNN you're
seeing two different things - there's no
difference of your Facebook feed than if
you have Fox News on the whole day or
CNN on the whole day we are manipulating
our consumption always also in that
scenario I know how to get two Americans
to know about the Belarusian thing just
as well as the Trump or the Hillary
Clinton or Obama machine and believe it
or not on Facebook I have a fair chance
in old media I don't okay let's argue
about that later
that's nothing to argue about you will
be historically wrong if you believe
what I just one more time trump 40 years
ago says we're kicking everybody out
there's he has his two best friends are
Rupert and les Moonves and he controls
the airwaves
you know like dictatorships this is
historical I'm not it's not my opinion
Fidel Castro did it
this is simple do you want two or three
people controlling the information or do
you want an open marketplace there's
nothing to argue about the conversation
that we need to have is our lack of
accountability of what we consume and
our curiosity the day after 9/11 I
started going to Al Jazeera's website
for the next year because I wanted to
learn that is way more important that is
what we need to be as a we need to be
empathetic and we need to hear other
points of view whether you consume that
on Facebook or on television or the
newspaper or the magazine that's a human
thing not a media distribution argument
don't blame the platform okay forget it
do you agree I do agree yes I do okay
someone wants to know if you ever we're
wrong a ton and let me tell you
something and this will make sense and I
think babban this has been the theme of
our like trip on this I bought crypto in
2014 not the earliest side friends
buying in 1112 but definitely not the
latest I have a lot of wins on my board
and early investing the reason somebody
would ask that question is I only talk
about things I know not things I think
I'm very basic I talk very little very I
mean just in a very narrow place I could
talk to you today about AR and crypto
currency and the Internet of Things I
just know there's a lot of people that
are smarter and better to talk about it
than me so the reason I feel like cocky
or are you ever wrong as I stay so
goddamn narrow and I talk about things
that have already happened I'm not
guessing up here my friends
I'm just social commentating on what
happened and that's it and so yeah I'm
wrong every day I just don't think it's
a good strategy to go on stage
and guess or a pinion 8 thank you you're
welcome
okay this one how do you use Facebook in
order to raise capital for a start-up
you run ads against employees of venture
capitalists is that a good answer
whoever asked the question what what's
really interesting about that is how
great this is the fact that I can make a
video on my phone for free articulate my
points of view of why my startup and the
I as a founder are special and then
spend $600 reaching every single
employee of every single venture capital
firm that could potentially want to talk
to me is the greatest opportunity in the
history of marketing and communications
that's how you use Facebook to get in
front now if you're not a practitioner
and you just talk about Facebook but you
don't know anything about it you might
not know that one of the ways you can
run ads on Facebook is clicking a button
that says go to these companies
employees in the feed you may not know
that that's it headline readers
practitioners my plea here today is for
you to become a practitioner if you're
the CEO and 90 years old or 22 years old
and you're gonna change the world and
everybody in between you have to be the
practitioner this is oxygen now you
can't have this as a nice-to-have
communication in today's world is the
value and you have to be good at it
Gary what's your best tip on delivering
quality at scale driving down the cost
of the production of the content the
biggest reason so many people are losing
is because they work with agencies or
internal people that aren't producing
enough at an efficient enough price the
reason for certain you know for the
hands that went up that follow me the
reason I started talking about
documenting versus creating is is
because I'm trying to produce so much
content having a man follow me around
with a camera
though narcissistic and crazy has
allowed me to create so much content
because so much is happening all the
time and then I'm DJing it I think the
biggest reason people are struggling is
everything is too perfect too fancy and
too subjective I let the market decide I
deploy humility with my content I
produce it I put it out there and then I
watch what happens not before and so
this camera is so much better of a
camera than what we have just six years
ago that cost thousands of dollars
you don't need unbelievable equipment
you need people that are native to
today's digital world to produce content
I would also say you have to use content
in multiple ways when I make a video I
turn that into audio I turn that into
the written word I get to write a 500
word essay on LinkedIn off of maybe an
answer that I just gave here today
because it was recorded then it's
transcribed create a framework that
creates enough quality content at scale
so you get a thousand at-bats instead of
13 which then allows you to not debate
quality quality is subjective period
until it hits the market and there's too
much audacity ego in the executives in
this room and in my own company of what
quality is before it goes out and I
fight that I fight that daily okay but
what homework can you do earlier on in
the process to ensure that this
documenting of this produce of content
has a good quality I mean working with
your values I go the way you do it as
you start and you put it out and then
you learn from the feedback which then
informs you on the next thing that you
do
it's iteration it's the reps you got to
do it you can't read or debate about
push-ups if you want the ROI of push-ups
you've got to do the [ __ ] push-ups
and that's how I think about content I
really do you can't read or debate about
the push-ups and I don't think you can
read or debate now I
even strategy and consumer insights I
live on it you should do that but that
has a moment and then you need to
produce at that scale because there's a
lot of platforms and a lot of attention
and it's fragmented and you got to give
your chance
yourself chances and by putting out 800
videos 30 of them are gonna teach you so
much for you to be better at the next
800 so major piece of advice that just
start yep okay and that is very
countercultural to organizations and
corporations they're in the business of
not starting that's I this is just a
question for me cuz I know one can order
you as a speaker with or without cursing
is this with or without cursing I really
hope this was with cursing I don't love
you guys take care you can't curse in
Stockholm you might as well close up
shop
you know stockholm can handle it what do
you do when your target audience is too
small for Facebook or LinkedIn
advertising tools to let your abs
through got it so your the segmentation
you're creating is too small who asked
that question ma'am
are you is that when you go for your
targeting it shows not a significant
enough so I think for now because
Facebook is so under priced i when I try
to do that think about a very
interesting strategy that you might like
you're trying to if you're going that
small you're trying to reach decision
makers right think a lot about the
people that influence the decision maker
the reason I love employees of as a
target is because you never know which
employee has the CEOs ear it's funny to
me in a my company of 800 that there's
3040 people that are very junior have a
lot of influence over me more than other
people that are very senior so I think
Facebook's so underpriced that you
should just add a wider range and give
away that money on the CPMs
it's still worth it to get to the group
that you're trying to reach so when I
get too small I just make it wider with
age or preference or I'll tweak it or by
location because I know that a lot of
big companies are there i widen it
because i still value it so much that
even wasting 80% of it I still think is
underpriced
because the other option is what's your
alternative right sending them a direct
mail or cold emailing them or sending
them a message on LinkedIn is not being
heard make sense
ish do we have a mic I want to have this
conversation
do we have one where's my microphone oh
right Jesus Christ that's insane you
were right there love it oh I guess it
makes sense but sometimes you know you
have the people you work for they don't
want to spend enough money no [ __ ] it
doesn't make it wrong right like I got I
get it now like I'm giving you the
actual answer if you tell me I only get
a $1,000 budget because you know they
don't believe in it
well that means you should go find
another job okay good thank you welcome
Hannah and I mean that you should find
another job if you unbelievably believe
that that what we believe in is right if
you don't well then you don't but to me
this is a real decade of the haves and
have-nots and you need to be smart
because the opportunity is great if you
actually understand it the fact that you
have targeted the fact that you have
targeted a segment that is not big
enough means you're ninety nine point
seven percent ahead of most of the
marketers in the world you need to take
advantage of that not just regress into
the Machine I wonder if her boss is here
or and if he's here or if she if that's
good or bad I think it's good because I
would hope that she or he listens to
this conversation and says screw that
guy on stage here's a couple of more
dollars let's prove him wrong and then I
hope that she makes good content so that
we could prove him or her wrong okay so
these are you know good arguments forget
getting an organization going but what
else could you tell for example are is
fifty nine years old not very keen on
spending money on social media listen I
you know I don't have a huge passion
that fifty nine-year-old Lars
spends money on social media I really
don't hey I don't give a [ __ ] about Lars
but be be the market will be the
decision maker I don't want people to
pander to me or to the history like I
think Lars and Susan should see what
it's like for themselves but if they
don't you know much bigger companies
than yours have gone out of business why
because of this argument right if my
argument was wrong then IBM would have
never let Microsoft happen then
Microsoft would have never let Google
happen Google would have never let
Facebook happen companies are built when
people don't see things or they see them
but they don't make change because the
people in the company don't actually
care about the health of the company
they care about themselves
super not fun super not fun to make the
proper investment into Facebook right
now if the head of marketing is bonus
ton efficiency on a thing that doesn't
score Facebook advertising okay
okay this is a personal question to you
from from someone in the audience have
you negotiated a deal with Apple to give
you $6 per view on iPhone you would have
made at least fifty thousand dollars by
now
I haven't Apple isn't super in the
business of negotiating directly with me
I haven't but uh what I would say is
this I
I have zero expectations of the other
person or platform I think one of the
biggest mistakes is people spend a lot
of time here saying well Facebook is
benefiting from me or this or that I
don't care when I go into business
whether it's a human or a platform I try
to figure out what I'm trying to get out
of it I always like if I'm getting a
little less out of it because then I
have leverage and that's how I think
about the world and so I don't think
about what Google and Apple and Facebook
are getting out of it I think about what
I'm getting out of it and if it's good
enough for me then that's fine by me and
I think a lot of people are miss playing
their strategies because of some
theoretical debate of who's getting the
better of the relationship I just try to
spend time on what I'm trying to get out
of the relationship and if those two
guys get 80% of the value because they
get all my content for free and it helps
them and they never buy a sneaker or a
book or anything I don't care it makes
me happy fine it's not why I'm doing it
and I think people get really caught up
in the wrong psychology good with an
increasing CPM on Facebook is the
Facebook stock the best investment today
I mean there's listen I like I think
actions are better than words I don't
understand Wall Street at all period
let's start there I don't trust those
[ __ ]
there's only two stocks that I buy ever
like ever Facebook and Amazon period
that is the only stocks that I bought in
the last five years because of Mark and
Jeff I believe companies are complete
replications of the leadership and I
think both of those guys are playing
long-term not to make the stock good in
the next 90 days and that's how you
actually win in business you invest in
the next things and so yes I think
Facebook is grossly underpriced at $175
now could macroeconomics crash the world
economy and that 175 go to 85 of course
but if you put a doubt well if you put
$175 into Facebook and you never need
that money ever I am convinced blindly
that you will return an investment on
that in a 10-year macro and that's how I
think about Amazon and Facebook it's
it's so it's been really great getting
to know you today and also yesterday in
Gothenburg but what will you do in the
next 15 years do you have a plan or is
it just you know lust or what are you
what's your objectives I don't know if
you heard earlier about the Nostradamus
thing my intuition is over the last year
or two I've become intoxicated with
impacting young men I have a lot of
young guys following me because of the
Alpha nature you can see in this is
probably the most alpha I am cuz when I
am on stage and nobody can talk back I
like that right and it allows me to be a
little more bravado and I'm a little bit
more of a showman when I'm one-on-one in
real life it comes down in different
direction but through my personality
I've gotten the attention of a lot of
young men and I'm really trying to teach
gratitude and empathy and kindness I
think these are weapons to why I've been
successful and I do have an ambition
over the next 15 years to become
unbelievably popular to that demo so
that I can make them a different version
than what they used to look up to
Rolexes and Porsches and parties
and and I do have some pretty lofty
historical legacy ambitions on my
ability to communicate and the way that
my mother raised me my intuition is that
every day that goes by that continues to
pull at me more yeah I want to be
historically correct and that really
comes true through when I went when I
when you spend time with you and I was
just wondering what did your mother do
she she taught me boy she's [ __ ] she
did everything right so what did she do
she over accentuate it when I did good
things meaning I remember clearly
opening the door for an elderly woman
when I was seven or eight at McDonald's
you know we're just going I just
remember this clearly I open the door
for this elderly woman my mom acted at
that moment like I won the Nobel Peace
Prize so she was very aggressive when I
was being kind or deploying empathy but
she she also didn't let me get away with
things so she knew I was gonna be
successful long before anybody else but
when I would get D's and F's on my
report card she would punish me for a
week or two even though she meant knew
she knew it meant nothing but she wanted
to teach me that things had
repercussions she was my biggest
cheerleader but she was practical and
and I'm so grateful for her and so she
built up my self-esteem to an
uncomfortably high level and she and she
raised three children with no help and
worked her ass off like I can't even she
did something's wrong but it came out of
what she did amazingly well like I can't
do anything for myself
like peel an orange or wash clothes cuz
my mom did everything for me she was
that hardcore she created an incredible
framework for me and to be very honest
with you
so much of what I do is out of guilt and
gratitude for how my parents raised me
and me not having anything and
having to work for it that I'm trying to
I feel like a lot of this is me giving
as lucrative as this is for me to get
paid for you know I'm sure you guys in
the organizers for my fee but I'm very
fortunate mmm the companies I'm building
my time allocation is far greater for me
and be in the business than to be here
for a day but this and knowing I was
gifted with a communication style that
is actually going to get three people
here to do something that has a lot to
do with the way I was parented I'm
desperate to give back the wisdom and
the framework that Sasha and tomorrow
gave to me
thank you Gary that's beautiful thank
you and one last question was from
someone who noticed can I get my selfie
taken with you and maybe they can buy
the books 100 percent let's go-oh at the
book oh that's a segue I wanted to do it
here sorry don't want to break the
system yes yeah it'll be a bowline I'm
ready to go yeah do we want that one
person to come up here now yeah who
wrote that let's go
it's [ __ ] selfie time
pleasure you ready Amina's common video
today also the Communist booboo TT Chris
Hadfield or Gary sally oxy
nearest-neighbor kisna foreign trotzdem
thank you thank you thank you guys thank
you thank you thanks hope you guys liked
it two things what do you think of the
keynote and number two what's your take
on the Stockholm Syndrome
[Music]